hello everybody so we will be starting
here in
two more minutes thank you all for
joining today this session would be
recorded
and it's also going to be live on the
fine
biotech youtube channel so if you would
also want to watch there it is going to
be live
so thank you again we are going to be
starting soon
uh so doctor oladipo and abu tayo is
also here
and as everybody is joining in i would
kindly request you to mute your my
and as you're all joining in i would
request everyone
to mute your microphones
so that you can hear our speakers
and uh hello elia if you can kindly make
aditya the co-host also
as we are starting thank you
please i will make your co-host please
keep it on mute for now
thank you
hello and welcome to this free webinar
on metagenomic data analysis this
introductory webinar will highlight the
applications of metagenomic sequencing
and methods of analysis for metagenomic
data
that are used in various research
biomedical
and agricultural applications
we are excited that this event has been
led
and organized by a dedicated team in
nigeria
that brings together experts who have
an interest in data driven research and
have
all recently completed our specialized
training
they are now certified and ready to
assist all of you in joining
the upcoming omix logic programs getting
registered
finding all of the necessary resources
and helping you
troubleshoot any technical or conceptual
challenges
you may come across this program
is led by adi
and sani hamzi i would now like to
invite
adidas our bioinformatics community
manager in africa
to talk about their omics logic programs
in africa
and introduce you to this metagenomic
collaborative program over to you
aborigine
thank you very much bixar i would like
to share my screen in a minute
yes we can hear you can you kindly make
your uh
slides visible to all of us
thank you all right
so thank you so much bipsa as you have
rightly said
we are part of david's logic nigerian
team myself
mr deputy mr sunny hamza
as a continuation of prime vertex
collaboration with continents and
countries
they are foreign to africa and enjoy our
comments with a myriad of programs
with research institutes academic
institutions
and therefore they have participated in
content evaluation
curriculum review and project design uh
the engineering team consists of a group
of passionate
citizen life scientists i am marital
abuser i'm the community manager
i'm in charge of managing the diverse
fledgling community in africa
where i tend to all the questions
clarifications
and queries from the members
we can be contacted i can be contacted
at african at pilot bow
that's our email address in the
beginning of the year
omix logic nigeria has we have
had a quite a number of programs we just
concluded our basic only logic training
which which held and still going on we
also have
a basic online training with matlab
convo
which is also going on at the moment in
ghana
there is a program between prime biotech
and
luguchi memorial university tagged by
informatics for infectious disease which
is a two months program
that is presently ongoing so that
there's a murder of programs the the
goal of
but the goal of prime biotech is to
is to teach logic programs
the main aim of enriching bioinformatics
training for beginners
students telecare researchers and even
advanced researchers
in the fields of clinical medicine
translational medicine
position oncology laboratory scientists
agriculturalists
molecular scientists and all fields in
life sciences
to be able to conceptualize cutting edge
research
with bioinformatic tools and
bioinformatics
analyses is based on this
that we we have conceptualized this
program
known as application of microbial
analysis and metagenomics
but before we talk about metagenomics i
would like to talk about
our partnership with the ceo and founder
of alex belgium
institute which is going to help more
students such as
gain access to mixed logic training and
research solutions
in nigeria to speak about the
significance of
data literacy and bioinformatics in
nigeria
i would like to invite and introduce
doctor
elijah crowley
and the lecturer at public university
he has a phd in microbiology
specifically medical
biology he has a master's degree in
medical microbiology and pathology with
options in biobiology and in the past
he has also been a lecturer director of
biology
technology and bioinformatics sex
liberation
and he continues to participate in
documentary training across nigeria
and the world in fact this part of the
team that is currently driving
the formulation of passing fascination
against
pascal in the country at this point i
would like to introduce
dr elijah allah
[Music]
hello everyone
yes we can hear your doctor okay good
afternoon everyone
uh it's nice to be on this platform this
time of the day and uh i'm very glad
that we are collaborating with omixlogic
the platform prime biotech and
for these upcoming course that is
starting next week
which is tag as application of microboom
and
metagenomics analysis in life sciences
next slide please
[Music]
yeah bioinformatics what we do at elix
as i've seen seen we train we support
and provide bioinformatics services to
meet the need of researchers
we have bioinformatics analysis and
planning we do data management and
analysis we
offer workshops and training on various
bioformatic topics for researchers and
institutions
and that is one of the things that is
ongoing now because we are collaborating
with a known and reputable organization
that has involved in bioinformatics
training
and we provide resources and allies
services for various research
projects now i'll be talking on
metagenomics
metagenomics is a study of metagenome
genetics materials recover directly from
environmental samples such as soil
water or physics and some other things
why microbiome is a study
of metagenome genetic material recovered
directly from humans or animals
then how can we apply this metagenomics
to let you know that this training we're
about starting
is very very essential for you for
anyone
it can be applied in agriculture in
energy
food and nutrition bad technology
biosensor
environment other industries medical
misnomers
i have one of the work i lay my hand on
as regards
agriculture that i discovered that a
metagenomics analysis of a soil sample
can guide us on the appropriate crop to
be planted
on it and this is a
an essential training that i employ
all of us to take part in it because it
is very very important
thank you once again viewers i think you
can take up the lead again
thank you so much
for your kind words and for organizing
this workshop along with us
i would now like to say
a few words about our omics logic team
and our collaborators who have made this
training possible
my name is peepsha bhaswas and i am the
omits logic community manager
responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users like
you who are part of our bi-informatics
community managed by find biotech
over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
all around the world that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result
the omits logic programs have been
thoroughly evaluated
and lead to excellent outcomes
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors
and peer example developing a growing
community
with shared passion for data-driven
research and appreciation
of citizen science enabling students
clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences
omics logic metagenomic training program
will be guided by
trainers who have ample experience with
bioinformatics in both
academic and industry applications i
will now
invite elia brodsky our ceo of spine
biotech to speak about metagenomic
sequencing and the upcoming program
over to you elia thank you very much
pizza
and welcome everybody to this webinar
i'm excited to participate in this
webinar because
i think that the microbiome provides
something
go on network thank you very much so
please keep your microphones
muted so that we can all participate
here
so metagenomics i think is an exciting
opportunity because it really provides a
snapshot into
how these communities that
live and function together as almost
like an
organ could be studied using next
generation sequencing so we can
gain insight into composition species
diversity and richness
and understand the functional
applications of metagenomics
so in the context of this program we're
going to find
different examples where we will see the
application of microbiome
we will learn how to analyze metagenomic
data
gain insight from data by mapping it
onto reference databases
and we will guide you on how to select a
project of your own
that could relate to either clinical
psychological maybe soil and
environmental samples
so we'll provide a number of curated
data examples for you to choose from
to work on a project of your own so
let's talk a little bit about the
history of metagenomics why
is metagenomic sequencing such an
impactful technology
so bacteria or the microorganisms in
general have been discovered back in the
1800s
in fact when bacteria was discovered to
cause different pathogenic functions in
clinical diagnostics
the first way to study bacteria was to
culture it
in the lab and so with the invention of
the microscope when the microorganisms
have been detected
then through culturing we understand how
bacteria different strains of bacteria
could have a major impact but today
with the advent of next generation
sequencing
we can study these microorganisms
without
isolating them in the lab and culturing
them we can actually study the full
composition of the communities that they
live in and a big part of understanding
those communities
relates to the study of the microbiome
using computational technology so when
we say
metagenomics we're really talking about
analysis of metagenomic data
using computational tools now as many of
you probably know from personal
experience
study the studying the microbial
communities
and trying to address how those
communities
colonize different parts of our bodies
is really something that requires an
understanding
of how they function and grow together
so here we have an example
of skin and in the pores of the skin you
can see how this bacteria can
colonize forming a film
which is very difficult to wash off
and disrupt and that is one of the
properties of the microbiome
that they form this relationship with
the host
and learn how to form a film
that is difficult to wash off and
difficult to remove
because it is integrated into the
epithelium
and so when you think of that property
of the microbiome
and you start thinking about different
surfaces and organs that this film can
develop on
we now have over 80 000 different
publications
about the microbiome function in
different places of the body
so here you can see a few examples of
how diverse these communities can be
but typically a distinct microbiota
a community of the microbes is formed
by dominant bacteria that you can see
here a few examples of those dominant
bacteria
and composition which means that
proportions
are stable and those proportions could
be disrupted
by different conditions and
challenged by different environmental
challenges
and we'll talk about that in a few
moments but what's interesting
is that in those 80 000 publications or
more that have been published on the
role of microbiome
more than half of those relate to the
gut
microbiome now the gut microbiome as
is fairly obvious is the densest
community of microbiota in our bodies
and that's
also a and that is also a the easiest
community of sample because we can take
fecal samples so we can observe
fecal microbiota throughout the lifetime
of a person it's easy to sample it's
easy to analyze because
we have such clear access to that
at the same time there have been some
recent studies
that have shown that that is not the
only microbiome that plays
a huge role in a variety of different
conditions so
let me go through some examples as you
can see here on the screen
this is a timeline of major microbiome
sequencing initiatives
that start around just after the
sequencing of the human genome
and so one of those is obviously the
major the gut microbiome but then
additional ones include the skin the
lung and
even the brain microbiome so the lung
microbiome
the microbiome of the lung has less
bacterial biomass so
it has less proportion of bacteria as
compared to the gut
but it displays a considerable diversity
the composition of the lung microbiome
is determined by
elimination immigration and relative
growth within its community so when you
think of the microbiome of the lung
imagine that certain bacteria are easier
to come in leave
the lung area and so we can
see the difference for example in
chronic conditions so many forms of
chronic lung disease
demonstrate exacerbations that drive
disease progression
and are now poorly understood but
there's growing evidence that supports
ways in which microbiota dysbiosis or
the
condition can influence the host defense
and immunity
and in turn may contribute to disease
exacerbations
it is key to understanding the
pathogenesis of chronic lung disease
that may reside in deciphering the
complex interactions between the host
the pathogen and resident microbiota
during stable disease and exacerbations
so lung is a major microbiota that is
continuous that continues to be studied
extensively
the brain is a novel area of microbiome
studies
over the past decade the development of
these sequencing technologies
have enabled extensive characterization
of
microorganisms including in the gut
lung skin and now in the brain and so
because we know uh that the
microorganisms that we coexist with can
influence our physiology immune system
even behavior we know that the brain
could be affected by dysbiosis or
changes in the microbiome
but previously it has been thought that
the brain is a sterile
environment protected from bacteria and
other
pathogens and so now there's first
evidence
that has shown that in fact microbiome
of the brain
could be affected so i want to point you
to an article
there is actually a discussion in the
literature
around the role of the brain microbiome
and here you can see some evidence
of sequencing reads mapped to individual
bacterial presence so this is very
interesting because
as i mentioned the brain was considered
to be a
sterile environment so not only that
we also know that there are other types
of microbiota
changes related to different diseases
and i think this is
a very exciting field and as we can see
here
there is a growing number of
publications continuingly is
expanding to offer us insights into
a variety of different types of
microbiomes
so you can see that about 20
of us investment in research
has gone to two phases of the human
microbiome project
which is creating the research resources
needed to study
the human microbiome in different areas
of the body and the different organs
and the goal of this human microbiome
project launched in 2007
is to create a toolbox of reference data
sets
computational techniques analytical
methods and
clinical protocols so we can see how
the investment in developing novel
technologies
and also an understanding of what
microbiome
is and how it plays a role in human
disease has
also enabled us to ask very specific
questions
about the role of the microbiome which
actually play a major role even in the
current pandemic so here you can see
an example of recent studies about the
role of microbiome
in the infection and it is hypothesized
that the changes in the microbiota have
an association with more severe disease
progression of covid19 so it's a very
interesting correlation
at the same time this pandemic
intersects with a decade-long decline
in microbial diversity and ancestral
microbes due to hygiene
antibiotics and urban living because of
the hygiene hypothesis so
what has happened over the past several
decades more people live in cities
there's more uniform level of
sterilization
access to sterilized food access to
antibiotics and different treatments
that reduce the overall
diversity of the microbiome as a result
the hypothesis
is that our body is less exposed to the
diversity
that could be very important to train
our immune system to recognize
different pathogenic microbes so the
current pandemic control measures and
practices are hypothesized to have an
even
broader and potentially long-term
effects on the human microbiome right so
there's so much
sterilization of hands there's so much
protection from the air that we breathe
and the different public public
situations that we visit so how will
this affect
the long-term immunity is a question
that needs to be studied
and so much is still uncertain or
unknown about the virus and how it's
going to affect
humans in the future but we understand
that we need to start
investing now in our understanding of
the role of the microbiome
and how it will go through with this
pandemic
so to summarize the function of the
microbiome
is to help with the differentiation and
the development of the immune system
to assist with food digestion and
nutrition to
perform energy generation in
conservation help with metabolic
regulation of fat storage
process environmental chemicals maintain
the skin and the mucosal barrier
and the prevent prevention of invasion
by pathogen so
these different functions in terms of
the human health are
critical when we study the microbiome
how can the microbiome be studied it
could be studied with
two primary technologies that are
available
uh today sequencing and mass
spectrometry
so when we speak about sequencing we can
look at
particular pathogens that are either
isolated
or by sequencing everything that is in
the microbiome
mapping it onto the reference dna or we
can also
analyze meta transcriptome when we
think about what products are going to
be produced by these microbes
when we speak about mass spectrometry
we're really talking about detection
of particular metabolites or
proteins that could be analyzed by their
mass composition so we can look at these
spectra and
design assays to study what products
are and what signaling pathways occur in
these diverse and complex
communities so one of the technologies
that we will focus on in this program
is metagenomics where we will look at
the composition as i mentioned before
the difference between different
other types of omix technologies and
metagenomics specifically
is that while other types of omix
technologies are focused on
studying a single organism a system
here we are going to study how
communities
of microorganisms form a distinct
functional community
and what does the dysbiosis or the
change in that composition
tell us about the condition that it
produces
and so here you can see an example of
two ways
of studying the microbiome either
looking at
operational taxonomic units that we can
characterize
the composition or culturing and still
use sequencing to understand
what amount of different areas in the
on this genome are being produced so
we'll talk about these different ways of
studying metagenomic data
and we will also learn about how to
prioritize
different hyper variable regions
in the metagenomic sequencing data so
that we can accurately detect
how different communities that have not
all been
annotated could still be studied for
composition so we'll talk about
the taxonomic classification
of bacteria using the 16s
ribosomal rna and the understanding of
taxonomy as far as composition
in different organs of the body and
comparison between different organs
in different conditions so ultimately
our goal with the analysis of sequencing
data is to be able to apply the
sequencing data to understand
the host response to study the
microbiome that includes the bacteria
and the viruses that are present in the
bacteria
and associate those with clinical or
phenotypic data and so that will be the
ultimate goal of this program
and we will see how similar and now
analytical thinking and logic
applies to the study of omics data
and integration of that omix data for
clinical and therapeutic applications so
that would be one of the primary
objectives for this program
let me briefly mention a few project
examples that we're going to be using
we have prepared a number of curated
data sets
publications that have been digested and
turned into tutorials
and we will discuss these at different
stages of the program so one of those i
mentioned already the human
microbiome project one of those is
a part of that human microbiome project
is called the american gut project
it's a citizen science project where we
will learn how to take that data
and generate a report just like what you
see right here
this is a report that is produced by the
american gut project participants
and where you can see the diversity of
different sample composition and
comparison to
other types of samples that are similar
to yours
and you can also compare those to
multiple tissues in the body
ages and populations and other factors
we will also talk about the gut brain
axis
or how gut microbiota can affect our
levels of anxiety and behavior and we
will talk about
methods of elucidating specifically the
role of the microbiome
by focusing on animal models so in
animal models what is useful is that we
can study
how distinctly a pro a portion
of this complex system so just the
microbiota
affects different types of behavior so
you can see here
that even though we can get insights
from patient data in animal studies we
can design
mechanistic studies that will really
illustrate
what is the role of the microbiome and
how that applies to a variety of
interventions
interventions using diet interventions
using
different types of antibiotics
intervention
using exercise and other factors
and it's important because anxiety is
just an
insight into overall psychological
conditions
and even clinical conditions that arise
potentially as a result and having an
impact by the microbiome so here's an
example
of china approving the first alzheimer's
treatment
that targets the microbiome and you've
probably heard of many
other examples of interventions using
fecal transplantation and other types of
interventions so here we see a number of
cancer therapies that have proposed to
be
affected by the microbiome composition
and therefore we understand how the
metabolic potential of these microbes
and the products that they produce
is an important area of study for us to
have more
personalized and more effective
treatments
for different types of patients now as
was mentioned already before me it's not
only
that the microbiome is affecting human
health
and disease we also will talk about
microbiome in
agriculture so how can we actually study
the composition of soil and
different bacteria that live on the
roots of plants
so there are there's the soil microbiome
the bacteria and the microorganisms that
live in the soil
and then there's also specific
communities that form around the
root nodes and those are play a major
role
in the way that the plants can absorb
different nutrients and interact with
the environment
and so we'll look at examples where the
interaction
and the composition of these microbial
communities
can play a role on the production
capacity so how much fruit is being and
plants how well they grow how resistant
and resilient they are
in different harsh conditions and also
as was mentioned how to select
the best soil for different crops and
for different objectives
so i hope that this will be an
interesting program for all of you to
consider
joining and to speak about how to join
this program
i want to pass it on to dr mohit
mazumner
who will guide you through the
registration process
thank you ilya yeah so
i'll just share my screen
okay hello everyone my name is mohit
mohit mazumdah
i'm one of the global representatives of
pine biotech
and our mission here is to simplify
complex bioinformatics research
and reach out to the student and
research community
to participate in advanced data-driven
biological research
through our modular and intuitive uh
multi-omics t-band for platform
and our coding and educational
portals
so this program omixlogic metagenomics
it is a specialized program
that not only takes you through the live
sessions courses
example publications and data sets but
also gives you an unique opportunity to
apply this knowledge to a real
metagenomics project
so as in all of our omics logic training
programs we will be leveraging online
we will be leveraging online sessions
such as these but
more more towards a hands-on activity
and then we will be also using
self-guided materials
and that are carefully and there have
been
validatedly designed and taken by
thousands of students
across different groups
and then we have practical assignments
and uh tutorials
that you can take to learn and go
deeper into these methodologies and
techniques
so this entire uh entire experience
is omics logic is in the omics logic
training
program sorry
okay so this online program is uh
equally rewarding rewarding for students
and researchers and specially suited for
project based
learning on a flexible schedule so all
of these sessions that we will be having
for this program
will be pre will be recorded and will be
emailed to our participants
other than that the program will cover
main aspects of
metagenomic sequencing analysis of 16s
rna and other aspects of microbiology
research
using bioinformatics so in these
sessions we will do hands-on
hands-on hands-on experience
using the tbi info platform and also we
will practice through our codomix logic
platform
and then we will learn about uh how you
know 16s metagenomic
data is processed and that results in a
table of annotated
16s rrna genes and then you can
read those map counts and that's that
table
that could be annotated by taxonomical
levels like
kingdom family genus species so learning
about
all those through hands-on experience
that we will be doing
through all these uh sessions along with
the materials
that will be shared with you as a form
of courses as form of
example projects or example um
example publications so at the end of
this program uh participants will be
conducting an independent
and there will be an opportunity to
conduct whether an
independent or a or a
group project where you will be able to
work on publicly do
available uh data sets and learn from
the
uh and learn about the impact of this
publications and the research on the
microbiome
so the sessions will be around the same
time
of 5 pm to 6 30 pm
west african time
[Music]
so our metagenomics bioinformatics
research training and that what we are
discussing today and all of you have
joined to learn about
uh is a research training which is well
structured
and it has been recognized by experts
from
academia and industry as well so talking
more about like how this program would
be
and what what these resources are that
i'm talking about
so this specialized training involves a
lot of
project examples because
learning by doing is one of the best
ways to learn
so starting from a level 0
or designed for beginners uh
so introduction to metagenomics you'll
start from a
basic level where you learn about the
keywords and the application
how this field has evolved do a advanced
level
where you will be further supplemented
by publication
a publication derived project examples
that are available
as educational projects so the
educational projects
uh are tutorials that explains
a peer-reviewed published research
project
in a simplified manner and explains the
data set
to next work on the analysis using the t
by info platform
so that will be uh the part of this
program and we will be doing that
by uh also showing you how to do that so
these are already described
in the courses and in the project
examples and then
we will have the live sessions to
supplement that and to answer your
questions
or the problems that you have faced or
any of those issues
that would be addressed so uh one of the
biggest you know advantage of this
program
it's just that uh the for those along
with the zoom
sessions you get a very important aspect
of
mentor support so our omics logic
programs are supported by experts
and they have a rich experience and rich
background in
both industrial and academic
bioinformatics research projects
and and both in education and training
so i think uh most of you have joined
today's
join today session have an interest in
metagenomic research
so i just wanted to talk a little bit
about metagenomic research and i know
easily i did talked about the
metagenomic research in length
so um so this research field is a newer
field
of biological research and it has
already
impacted us so i just wanted to uh
show you some examples so
that recent study about the gut
microbiome and kovid 19
that uh elias talked about so the uh
one of such study is like where the
author concluded that the
individual gut microbiome may affect the
body response to suscof2 infection
which means like the gut gut
bacteria might influence both
short and long term effect of the
infection and how the gut microbiome can
affect uh brain health in the case of
uh neurodegenerative diseases that might
lead to you know better and
easier treatment for brain diseases
another example is this uh segmented
filamentous bacteria in gut so in green
you can see they are over simulated
uh the brain the immune system of a
pregnant mice that have done that have
an
infection so that altered its uh
fetus brain development so that's one of
the aspect
research aspect so this field of
metagenomics is gaining insights from
micro microbes and microbiota
has generated like enormous interest and
not just
for academia or academics but also in
industry so in february 2019
therapeutics in massachusetts they
raised 25 million dollars in financing
to develop therapeutics for
neurodegenerative diseases
and neuropsychiatric diseases another
company
is uh the finch therapeutics in
summerville
so they are are developing an oral
microbiome drug for
autism uh spectrum disorder asd so
they are now that was announced in last
year september and they have raised 90
million uh 90 million dollars
for that so there's a lot of research
that is
ongoing and there is a lot of uh
requirement
in industry and for a postdoctoral level
as well for this kind of research
so one of the other aspect is to develop
an understanding of metagenomics
research experience
so so to do that one needs to have a
good understanding of the
way data is prepared so in the context
of the program we will be discussing
data sets that are available for
analysis and study of the role
microbiome
plays in agriculture biomedical research
epidemiological studies of infectious
diseases
such as those
so during the last program and we had
this program
in september uh
there were a lot of uh interesting
particip interesting studies that
happened during that program
so uh that resulted in numerous
independent pro independent projects
some of them are highlighted here
so these projects were then peer
reviewed by experts so that's how it
works
so in towards the end when you know that
how this works and you have an idea and
you want to work on a project
we ask you to submit a proposal so there
are already ongoing projects that you
can join
there are already uh projects on the
educational site that
that you can further work on and the
third aspect
is the independent project so many of
these researchers who are working on
their own research projects
or they are working in their phd in
their labs uh they have some research
questions that could be addressed
using bioinformatics and that could
actually enhance
their you know publication uh quality
and the quality of research or answer
their questions with a complete
understanding so for that purpose
like many of these researchers submitted
their research proposals
and we went through a peer-reviewed
process by
uh by you know sharing those research
uh proposals to experts and then we got
that feedback from them
and then we kind of analyzed it
ourselves
and then we have a session with the
participants
uh discussing their research proposals
so some of those research proposals were
really really
exciting and interesting uh some of them
were about the
international space station and uh the
data that have been collected
in the human missions for other
long-term missions
uh in somewhere some of them were about
finding relationships between
saskov 2 and how metagenomics can help
in
understanding the virus toxicology and
transmissibility
so those are some of the aspects of this
program
and uh without taking much of your time
uh i would just wanted to say that i'm
really excited to be a part of this
collaborative research program
and i'm looking forward to meeting the
participant to guide through the
uh right through the resources and then
developing logical and conceptual
understanding of the ban
of bioinformatics research uh so
and to talk more about the program
resources and registration
let me invite biepsha to guide you
through
guide us through the process thank you
thank you so much uh dr mohit for such
an insightful presentation
for different parts of this program we
will leverage
omics logic resources that you can use
to learn
more about metagenomics these will
include a synchronous coursework with
theoretical material
quizzes in practical assignments our
cloud-based
analytical server where you can analyze
large metagenomic data and visualize
results
the omex logic code playground where you
can practice
coding in rn python as well as a
repository of
project example so let us start
by signing up to our platform which is
the
edu tbio info platform if you already
have an account you can log into the
platform
if you do not have an account then you
can either sign in using your
email id or you can utilize any of these
social media logins
to sign into the platform this will get
you
started on your own bi-informatics
journey
the first course that we recommend to
you
is the introduction to metagenomics
which will familiarize you with the
concepts of
metagenomic data analysis
and you can also find the link in the
chat box thank you
aditya for sharing the link you can also
see some of these reviews by previous
participants who have taken this course
so this is a free course
please feel free to create an account
and start taking this course
you will also discover that this comes
in a set of three courses starting with
introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics 1 and metagenomics 2.
and you if you are registered for the
program you will have access to all
three of them
as well as a number of curated data sets
prepared as projects like the
american gut microbiome gut brain axis
and the role of microbes for skin
conditions like
acne eczema and more which already elia
and dr mohit has spoken about
let us now talk a little bit more about
the practical analysis
approaches we will cover in the program
like kind 2
data 2 pipelines and phyloseq
throughout this course you will be given
directions to access the
t bio info platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of metagenomic
data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as
data management and analysis cloud
infrastructure
to run by informatics pipelines
different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections of this
multi-omics pipeline
the visual interface of the tibia info
platform will enable users to quickly
build
logical graph of their analysis
and understand each steps significant
in running this pipeline for
interested in implementing
kindly keep your microphones muted
[Music]
thank you so for those interested in
implementing these pipelines for your
own we will also offer guidance and
references
that can be used to effectively install
all the needed packages for these
pipelines
so behind many of these methods are
scripts written in popular coding
languages such as
r and python these are explained in
tutorials you will have access to on our
codemix logic platform
these include beginner tutorials on data
importing
preparation for analysis and standard
visualization of
process data more specialized packages
with publication ready outputs will also
be covered in more
advanced lessons that is why this
program is built to provide
students of all backgrounds with a clear
perspective
on big data analytics machine learning
and artificial intelligence in
application to omics data
and research clinical and industry
applications
our omics logic step-by-step process is
enabled by
access to complex tools via a simple and
intuitive interface at the same time
exposing participants to analysis logic
in the context of real data sets and
extrapolation of this logic
to a variety of projects and data sets
with assistance from mentors
and technical support now let us take a
look at some participants from a recent
bioinformatics
training programs in nigeria who have
been very successful here you can see
farida bashar who has gained over 10
000 points and have completed multiple
courses denoted by the course
certificates so the free course that we
have shared
also comes with a certificate of its own
so if you are looking forward to earn a
certificate
you can complete introduction to
metagenomics and you will be earning a
certificate
like foreign mojib is also working
towards completing the courses
and as you can see in both these cases
the participants have
a complete profile so once you are
logged into edut bio info the first step
is to update your profile and an updated
profile comes with a full
picture and your full name as this is
the name which will be reflected
in the asynchronous course certificate
that you would be getting
and you can also learn more about these
participants via the edu link
so you can also be one of those
participants who are featured in
one of our webinars in our social media
channel so please feel free
to make sure that your profile is
updated and
aditya has also shared all of the
profiles of these two participants
your achievements in the program are
denoted by the points
as we saw in the last two slides so once
you complete
this training you will receive either a
certificate of excellence or a
certificate of completion
depending on the number of points you
achieve and this is an effective
tracking mechanism why because the
points you receive are not only from the
course work that you do
but also by running pipelines on the tbi
or info server
or by using the codomix logic platform
for running the codes
so all of these platforms are linked
together so all of your activity
is tracked and they add to your points
so you or as well as your faculty
or even if you are coming as part of a
university can track your progress
even our mentor team can track your
progress
to start with the program please
register on the edut bio info portal
and once you are signed in we will be
sending you
a link that will ask you to register for
the program
and you can visit that link to complete
your registration
now the cost of this program is 150
usd and we understand that
this may not be an affordable option for
a lot of participants here
so we also have a scholarship option for
students
you would need to complete the necessary
requirements to be awarded the
scholarship
please start by filling out the form
that you will see in the chat box
if you are interested in applying for
this one month training program
and now i'm going to be opening this
session for
questions and also i would like to
ask you all to see a poll
right now on your screen where we would
want to know more about you
so the first question here is what is
your
educational background the second
question is what are your areas of
research interest
so we do know that a lot of you are
interested in metagenomics research but
you may also be interested in either of
these
research areas so please feel free to
share
and the third question is where are you
from
so i will keep the poll on and we would
try to address any questions that you
may have
so i see that a lot of the questions
that came
in are regarding the
different resources or if you can get
started if you are a beginner
yes you can definitely get started with
this program
even if you are a beginner because we
will start with basic courses like
introduction to metagenomics which will
give you an
overview of this full metagenomic
training and metagenomic data
analysis can you see the poll on the
screen
yes we can see the po jay kitchen are
you not able to see the poll on the
screen
okay so i'll keep it on for a few more
minutes and if you have
any other questions then you can please
put them down in the chat box
and again this session is open for
everyone uh to participate in so
please go ahead and complete your
registration we do not have a long time
before
february 16 so we would be starting it
next week so thank you again
for making time to join today's session
yes so after we leave uh i would like to
just there was a question on how to
get access to the platform so maybe i
could just
explain uh how that would work
sure yeah so should i stop sharing my
screen
uh yes please
so um the server platform
offers a cloud based
account where you can store large data
sets
you can import data sets directly from
ncbi
upload your own fastq files and reuse
them multiple times
and also analyze process
and interpret the results so first of
all when you get to this platform
you will see this link right here in the
menu that says
access so what you need to do is
fill out your name that information
comes to us by email
and we will review your application and
send you the details
and there are three different options to
use this
the first one is the free option so
using the free
option you understand how different
sections of this platform
operate and what types of outputs
and inputs they utilize for example
since we're talking about metagenomics
here we have a demo pipeline for one of
the data sets that we will discuss in
detail during the program
it is a data two processing pipeline
with interpretation using phyloseq which
is a package in r
so you start the pipeline by clicking on
start
here you have a little explanation of
what the
overall idea behind this pipeline is
then the data 2 pipeline consists of
number of different steps
that are specifically designed to
eliminate the noise
in the data and make sure that the
result the output
is cleared from all of the contamination
because you're talking about many
different unannotated reads
from a whole variety of different
microbes
finally when the data is analyzed
based on a database called the silva
database
now you can study what is the
relationship between different groups of
reads
based on their taxonomic
association using a phylogenetic
analysis called
ape which produces biome files
that could be visualized and further
analyzed for their composition
using this package called phyloseq
so finally when your data is processed
and analyzed you will see
some pipeline outputs and you can really
see what to expect
so what are these otus what is the
taxonomy table
what are the different plots that you
can get from filoseq
etc so this is an example for the free
tier you anyone can register and get
this demo pipeline for free you can see
a variety of different examples
including the microbiome transcriptome
genomic data analysis mass spec
structural biology
data integration and modeling data
mining and machine learning
and other specific pro processing
pipelines for
virology such as different strains in
covet 19
detection of mutations and things like
that so this is a full-fledged
bioinformatics analysis platform that
will allow you to
process analyze and visualize your onyx
data
now included with this as i already
mentioned are some
packages in r and python that you could
learn how to read modify and adapt
to whatever you want to do with them
also learning
how to code along the way and so the
second resource that beeps
demonstrated with it was the code
omixlogic
playground and here we also have a
section dedicated to metagenomics
so this is going to be covered again
extensively in the program itself
but you will learn how to perform
analysis of sequences
visualization composition statistical
analysis and a number of other things
that are critical for anyone that wants
to learn how to make the most out of
their microbiome data
so the unique part of this is that you
actually get to see
the code and try to run it yourself
so you learn about the code you see the
different outputs
and then you can actually try it by
yourself
so here we have created a way for us to
take the scripts and run them in our
studio on the cloud and really
eliminates a lot of the
challenges that people have with
setting up their environment so here for
example you can see i've analyzed the
data set
and i can see the composition of my
sample
based on proportion or based on
abundance
so this is a little bit of an overview
of some of these tools on how to
register again many of these resources
are completely free
so if you don't want to join the program
and you don't have maybe
the time or you want to do this on your
own pace
you can register here for free start
learning and when the time comes you
will see
different types of additional in-depth
resources like actual research
capabilities of the platform where you
can upload your own data and manage it
using
ftp and on the coding
we also have some advanced course work
like machine learning and data science
that could get you farther along with
the data that you have
thank you alia so there is a question
from iodine day
is it possible for one to jump directly
on the core metagenomics where we can
use the actual
r scripts yeah so as i showed
the same r scripts are offered there in
any kind of processing of data
it's not the scripts that typically
limit you
it's the infrastructure so if the data
is big
and many of the current studies include
hundreds if not thousands of samples
and the analysis you can do them on your
computer but unless you have a server
stack
you're going to be waiting for a long
time for those pipelines to finish so
that's why we have a lot of these
pipelines implemented on our big data
high performance computing
infrastructure for you to be able to
work with real data sets
but once the data sets are percent
processed and they're ready as a table
you can then do the downstream analysis
and visualization
in r and in python and that is a big
part of what we will do in the program
as well
first of all understanding the logic why
are we doing what we are doing
and what do these visualizations mean
and then doing it
ourselves in r and learning how to
manipulate the data
wrangle it visualize and interpret
uh thank you so much elia so i would
want you all to
go ahead and join our social media
groups
so we are having an active group in
linkedin
and if you go through the group you can
see that this is a group not only for
students or researchers but
you would see that there are a lot of uh
scientists who are joining us in this
group from all
around the world so this gives an
opportunity to be part of a larger
community
as well as we have a group in facebook
so whichever platform
is easy for you please go ahead and join
our platforms
and now to clear some of the doubts that
a lot of you are having regarding the
registration
so if you are already registered on edut
bio info i'm putting the link in the
chat
then this is the link to check out so
you can note
that here is a 150 dollar the price
there is a 33 percent discount that
would be emailed to you
if you have already shared your email id
or if you were already registered for
this
program so you would have to check out
via this link and you can also see the
different courses
that are included as part of this
training program
so please visit this link and if you are
someone who is looking for a scholarship
i
require a scholarship here is a
scholarship
form again i am posting it here in the
chat box
so please make sure to fill up each of
these
fields in the scholarship form and maybe
let us take a look at this together
so that we know what are the different
things that we have to
fill up here so you see you have email
first name last name the company an
organization
your current level of education
graduation year
currency gpa any other awards
and the reason you're applying for the
scholarship you have to upload your cv
and please make sure that you're also
mentioning a reference from your college
or university
and also this field so all of these
fields should be filled up for that
scholarship to be accepted and once that
scholarship is accepted
or we want to discuss more with you we
would set up a meeting with you
and your reference so please make sure
to mention
the correct name and email addresses of
your references
will set up that meeting and that
meeting will decide
whether that scholarship is going to be
given to you
so please go through this process and if
you are joining us directly please
follow this link
and we will also be sending you this
entire link to join the program and send
you an email with all the details about
the program
and this scholarship may either be a
full scholarship or only a partial
scholarship that would be decided
while you're having that conversation
with you and your reference
so it would be dependent on that meeting
that we have with you
and i'm moving on i would also want to
highlight
two more programs that we are having
very soon
so this program is again a specialized
training on precision oncology so
here is the link again if someone is
interested in joining
this program
this is starting on march 15 and we also
have an
ongoing program for researchers and
students
who are interested in working on their
own
project so this is either a three months
or a six months
project development program where we
work closely
with a student to help them work on
their own novel project
and our team of mentor guides that
student right from the training
to the completion of that project so
if you are joining like a three months
program
we are here to make sure that you can
come up with a project of your own
and of course you would have to give in
quite some time of yours
to be able to come up with a novel
project while
if you are also intending to go beyond
just a project and aim towards say
a poster presentation or even working on
a publication
which can be a very long drawn out
process so we definitely recommend
six months or more to be able to make
sure that that
project is ready to be presented to
everyone else so this is
again another one of the offerings that
are available for students
clinicians or researchers who are
interested in
attending a research program like this
and with this i would like to thank you
all for attending today's session and i
hope you enjoyed
this session and it was informative to
you and hope to see you in the upcoming
week
in the microbiome and metagenomic data
analysis program
thank you everyone
you